SEVERANCE:
Tech companies have
laid off tens of thousands of employees but
they’ve also handed out hundreds of thousands
of dollars worth of severance to each and every
employee that was laid off. Meta offered 16 weeks
of base pay plus another 2 weeks of base pay for
every year of tenure. Google offered an identical
package but some companies even took it to the
next level. Salesforce, for example, offered a
minimum of 5 months worth of base pay and that’s
just base pay. Most severance packages also came
along with stock vesting through the current
quarter or more, 6 months of health insurance,
the opportunity to cash out PTO, and compensation
for the 60 day notification period. So,
most of the people who were laid off from big
tech walked away with nearly 6 months worth of
full compensation. This is no doubt how severance
should be handled if layoffs are required but
were these layoffs even worth it? I mean, these
companies are basically committing to pay these
employees for the next 6 months. A director for
example would walk away with $400 to $500 grand.
Not to mention, they never really stopped hiring
either. Yes, we always see headlines about Google
or Meta implementing a scary indefinite hiring
freeze but this isn’t actually true. While hiring
is definitely slower and more selective, Google
literally has over 1900 job openings posted as we
speak. So, if these companies are just hiring back
new people as they layoff their existing staff,
where exactly is the cost savings? Sure, they can
pay the new people a marginally lower salary of
10 or 20%. But, for a company like Google or
Microsoft, saving 10 or 20% on 10 or 20,000
employees is a rounding error. Not to mention
all of the terrible PR. I mean just look at
Apple. They’re coming off as some sort of heroes
for not doing layoffs while Meta is presented as
suffering from Typhoid fever or something. So,
join me as we figure out just how much these
companies are actually saving from layoffs and
the real reason they’re resorting to layoffs.
COST SAVINGS DEBUNKED:
Let’s start off by taking a look at the
supposed benefit of layoffs: reduced operational
expenses. Given how much these companies pay,
the apparent savings are actually quite large.
Google for instance has a median compensation of
$295,000. Facebook comes in just under that
at $292,000. These are already big numbers
but that’s just direct compensation of base
salary, stock, and bonus. These companies
also hand out extremely generous insurance
plans, 401k plans, retirement plans, free food,
smartphones, monitors, phone plans, software
subscriptions, airplane tickets, hotel rooms,
and office space. They also have to pay social
security and medicare tax on these salaries,
so the indirect compensation itself easily adds
up to another $50 to 100k. Let’s call it $100k
to give these companies the benefit of the doubt.
This means that the average employee is costing
Google and Facebook roughly $400,000. So, how much
exactly are the layoffs saving? Well, Google has
thus far laid off 12,000 people and Facebook
has laid off 21,000 people. At $400k a pop,
Google is saving $4.8 billion per year and
Facebook is saving $8.4 billion per year. This
was the first time that I started thinking that
maybe the layoffs were worth it. I mean, we’re
talking about billions of dollars every single
year. That is until I faintly recalled that not
a single one of these companies are losing money.
In fact, they’re not even remotely close to losing
money. Some of them are straight up posting record
profits. And when you contextualize these savings
with how much these companies are pulling in,
it just becomes even worse. In terms of revenue,
Google pulls in just under $300 billion per year
and Facebook pulls in just over $100 billion per
year. So, the savings only equate to 6 days worth
of revenue for Google and 26 days worth of revenue
for Facebook. Obviously, they haven’t hit the
jackpot, but with that being said, savings are
savings. Why make less money when you can just
make more money which brings us back to the idea
of maybe the tech companies were right for doing
layoffs until you consider natural attrition.
Here’s a secret. These big tech companies are
actually really bad at employee retention. And
it’s not because of bad pay or bad work culture
maybe with the exception of Amazon. It’s actually
because most FAANG level tech bros are simply
not dependent on the company. A lot of them
have enough money to retire by the time their 30,
so it’s not like they’re held back by their job.
As such, they’re constantly looking for better
opportunities and leave as soon as they find one.
This is why the average tenure at most tech
companies is only 2 years. For Google, this
corresponds to an employee turnover rate of 13%.
Let me put that in another way. Google has to hire
25,000 people every year just to maintain
their headcount. Meta has to hire 11,000,
Microsoft has to hire 28,000, and Apple has to
hire 21,000. And all of that is with just a 13%
turnover rate. Some of these companies have
turnovers that’s are way worse which raises a
rather interesting question: could these companies
have just stopped hiring and waited it out?
ALTERNATIVES TO LAYOFFS:
Well, let’s just say, the minute that the first
big tech company announced mass layoffs, this
strategy became a lot harder. Suddenly, people are
scared to join that new startup or even switch to
another big tech company. In fact, I bet natural
attrition is the lowest its been since like 2008,
and it’s all thanks to Meta who kicked off the
big tech layoff season back in November. But,
this isn’t to say that this strategy became
impossible. I mean, Apple and Nvidia are
leveraging this strategy as we speak. But, if all
the big tech companies weathered out the storm
together, the strategy would’ve simply been even
more effective. In fact, it would’ve negated the
need for layoffs altogether for many companies.
Take Google for instance. They have to hire
25,000 people every year just to keep up with
turnover. This means that instead of laying of
12,000 people and giving them ridiculous severance
for 6 months, Google could have just implemented
a real hiring freeze for 6 months and they
would’ve ended up with the same head count and
the same cost savings. This idea is simply even
truer at Microsoft. So far, they’ve laid off
10,000 people but they could’ve just frozen
hiring for 4.5 months. In fact, for Microsoft,
it might’ve been cheaper to freeze hiring than
to do layoffs. And don’t even get me started on
Amazon. Their attrition is so dang high that they
straight up measure it on a weekly basis. They
lose 3% of their warehouse workers every single
week, and to be honest, I don’t think their tech
turnover is all that much better. The reality
is that for most companies, freezing hiring for
6 months would’ve accomplished the same goal as
layoffs all with way better PR. The only notable
exception to this would be Meta who would have to
freeze hiring for 2 years which just goes to show
how much they overhired. But for everyone else,
the situation wasn’t that bad. Also, freezing
hiring isn’t the only alternative. There’s plenty
of other solutions like just cutting bonuses. Out
of the average Googlers $300,000 salary, about
$30,000 is just a bonus. So, if Google had
simply cut the bonus of all 190,000 employees,
that itself would’ve saved $5.7 billion or $900
million more than the layoffs. Also, that’s not
even considering that directors, and VPs, and
executives have exponentially larger bonuses. But,
Google didn’t even reduce bonuses, they simply
delayed them. Another solution would’ve been to
offer early retirement and voluntary resignations.
This is usually what Southwest Airlines leans into
whenever they’re going through a turbulent period
like the pandemic. And news flash, Southwest has
never had layoffs despite having low single digit
profit margins. So, if Southwest can get through
without layoffs, tech companies definitely can
with their 30-40% net margins. The only argument
against these alternative solutions would be
that companies give up control as to who
leaves. With layoffs, companies can slash
certain departments and titles. But, this can
simply be corrected for with strategic hiring.
If you want to get rid of recruiters, just stop
hiring recruiters. With time, things will level
out how you want. But then, if the savings from
layoffs are marginal at best and there’s little
strategic benefit to layoffs, what’s the
real reason that everyone is doing layoffs?
THE REAL REASON:
To get to the root of why companies are doing
layoffs, we have to first identify who exactly
wants layoffs. It’s obviously not the employees
but it’s also the employers either. Do you really
think these companies want to be the bad guy? They
already have a bunch of bad rep regarding invasion
of privacy, data collection, and monopolization.
Reputation wise, one of the only factors that
are going in these companies’ favor nowadays is
that they pay well and have happy employees. So,
it makes no sense to screw that up as well. Not
to mention all of the damage layoffs cause to
company morale and ongoing projects. Tech CEOs
more than understand this and that’s why most of
them don’t want to do layoffs. Take Tim Cook for
example. He’s taken a pay cut from $265 million
in 2020 to $49 million this year. Similarly,
Zoom CEO, Eric Yuan has taken a 98% paycut. Now,
I’m sure it’s hard to sympathize with these
billionaire CEOs. Oh no, Tim is only making
$50 million this year boo hoo, but bear with me.
The point is that these CEOs are doing their best
to prevent layoffs themselves. Hold on wait a
minute. What do I mean they’re trying to prevent
layoffs. They’re literally the ones approving
them. Well, as far as the public is concerned,
that’s true. The CEOs are the ones who
take all the blame and bad rep for layoffs,
and they’re definitely by no means saints,
but they’re not the ones behind layoffs.
The ones who are really behind the layoffs are
people like this. You probably have no idea who
this guy is because people like this lurk in
the shadows but they pull all the strings. This
is Christopher Hohn: the founder of TCI Fund
Management. He’s a multi billionaire with a $6
billion stake in Google. And since last November,
he has been constantly sending letters to Sundar
and calling out Google amongst investor circles.
“We are writing to express our view that the cost
base of Alphabet is too high and management needs
to take aggressive action.” “The company has too
many employees and the cost per employee is too
high.” Within hours of this letter being sent,
Google shares were up 4.4% which doesn't sound
like a lot but for a company as big as Google,
we’re talking about a market cap increase of over
$50 billion making it crystal clear that this is
what rich investors want. The reality is that
people like Christopher Hohn have no idea about
tech. They think it’s like some sort of factory
where you have to maximize output and minimize
input. That’s not how tech works and tech
CEOs obviously know that but that’s completely
irrelevant. You get a dozen Christopher Hohn’s
together and boom, it’s Sundar or Tim that’s out
of a job. So, naturally, they do as they’re asked
even though it’s not all that effective. Also,
I don’t want to understate the aggressiveness of
these investors. After the first round of layoffs
at Google, the first thing Chris did was send
in another letter asking for far more. He wanted
Google to cut a total of 40,000 jobs and reduce
pay substantially. And Chris is just one example.
Most big investors do the same thing just behind
closed doors. And that’s why everyone is suddenly
doing layoffs even though its effectiveness
is questionable to say the least. Something
else that’s questionable is Goodwill’s
Goodwill. Check out this video to learn more.